Speaker 1: I want to go next to the fear
mongering around so-called vaccine passports
because something incredible has been taking place
at Fox News. Fox News hosts have been slamming
the possibility as well as the use of so-called
vaccine passports, which basically means proving
you've been vaccinated in certain situations
in order to be allowed to do something or to
go somewhere. Fox hosts have been fear mongering
around so-called vaccine passports for months now
without mentioning that Fox News is using a
vaccine passport. We're going to look at the
details momentarily, but if you want to seriously
criticize the use of such vaccine passports, have
the gall to say, my own employer is doing it right
now, but they won't tell you that. There's a very
good write up about this in Rolling Stone by Peter
Wade called Fox Rails against vaccine passports,
uses vaccine passports, explaining that Tucker
Carlson and other hosts have railed on air
against the idea of so-called vaccine passports,
but never told their audience that Fox News is one
of its own hypocrisy, spreading lies and
fear mongering or well-known staples at Fox.
But Monday's news about how Fox Corporation
has already implemented a vaccine passport type
program for its own employees that is similar
to what hosts Tucker Carlson and Laura Ingraham
have loudly railed against is a window into how
little they actually care about the well-being
of people who watch their shows. Businesses that
require employees to provide proof of vaccination,
commonly referred to as a vaccine passport, have
been slammed frequently on the network. Tucker has
called the idea the medical equivalent of Jim
Crow. Segregation is laws. Another host compared
the requirements to communist East Germany, and
Laura Ingraham has falsely claimed that such
programs are akin to tracking mechanisms.
But not one host has told their audience
about Fox Clear Pass, which works for Fox
employees, the exact same way most vaccine
passport systems do in other businesses. Listen
to this. An internal Fox email, first reported
by Ryan Grim and also obtained by Rolling Stone,
spells out how Fox employees were instructed how
to enter their vaccination information into the
company's passport program called Fox ClearPath,
in order to avoid Fox's mandated requirements
to social distance and wear masks while at work
sent on June 22 to all Fox News staff,
the email outlines how vaccinated staff
can prove they're vaccinated status by entering
info into a workday. Human resources system.
Employees who prove vaccination can get a fox
clear pass, which allows them to bypass screening
procedures. They have a vaccine passport at
Fox News, and Laura and Tucker and others
have railed against this without mentioning my own
employer has it. The details are fully vaccinated.
Individuals who have entered their vaccination
info into work day are not required to wear
a mask or socially distance while at work. Let
me remind you of all of these instances of fear
mongering around exactly this type of vaccine
passport. This is a nice little compilation
from Media Matters. Take a listen to this.
Speaker 3: Left is going to begin the push
for vaccine mandates. Oh, no. And vaccine
passports. No vaccine passports. Oh,
yeah. Plans for a vaccine passport. This vaccine
passport, the vaccine, passport, vaccine,
passport. There's going to be growing pressure
across all of corporate America to force proof
of vaccination status.
Speaker 1: Whoa.
You mean like by Fox News, right, Laura?
Speaker 3: Movement for everything.
Just like no mask, no entry, no vaccination,
no entry. Vaccinated only sections. So
vaccination, segregation, the very same
people, literally the very same, who just the
other day told us that segregation was immoral,
are now enforcing segregation
Speaker 1: like my employer,
only making the unvaccinated wear masks
Speaker 3: a turning point. USA,
we are going to give it everything. We have to
make sure that students are not going to have to
live in a medical apartheid because they don't
want to get the vaccine. Medical Jim Crow has
come to America. We still have water fountains.
The unvaccinated would have separate ones right
into the bullies on this vaccine passport issue,
the ongoing mass mandated school restrictions.
And they'll never stop chipping away at your
liberty and your privacy. And by the way,
just so you know as proof,
if you want to get a job,
you'll need your vaccine papers.
Speaker 1: And I even need to show
them in order to not wear a mask here.
Speaker 3: If you're worried about being
forced to show your papers for travel,
well, you should be that we are on the
verge of East German style. Show me your papers.
Speaker 1: All right. So you you guys get the
point, the hypocrisy, guys, the hypocrisy. And
so there's actually a couple of hypocrisies,
and it's important to understand all of them.
And I don't think that the anti vaccine.
Right. Understands them or would believe them
if they were confronted with them. No. One,
the people warning you about the vaccine passports
are saying nothing about the fact that they work
at a place where the vaccine, passports, that's
number one. But maybe even more importantly, more
hypocritically, more cartoonishly dystopian. Is
that the very people warning you about vaccines?
Many of them have been vaccinated,
but refuse to say that public.
And I don't know which is the bigger hypocrisy,
I don't know which is the bigger danger.
We're going to have more on this
on The David Pakman Show Instagram.
Make sure you're following us there at
David Pakman show coming up after this.
I won't even tell you what it is because it's so
horrifying. We'll just talk about it in a moment.